c'est sûr qu'on a des questions qu'on
veut poser aux autres chefs de parti
c'est un peu normal ils ont pris les
engagements qui dans certains cas sont
un peu étonnant et c'est de défendre nos
propres choix
alors moi je veux agir dans le respect
des gens qu'il aime la boue pour moi là
c'est pas que c'est parce que ça
m'intéresse pas mais sans imposer aux
gens de laisser manger la laine sur le
dos comme on dit chez nous si madame
marois choisissent à avoir goûté aussi
vous donnerais pas mais question que je
posais madame marois
monsieur couillard parce qu'un de mes
objectifs c'est de voir si on fait leur
devoir
s'ils sont prêts à gouverner au québec